mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
étions bien le 15 août plage bondée
soleil plus ou moins cela dépend des
endroits ville envahie par les touristes
pas de doute c'était bien l'ambiance
traditionnelle de la mia ouf et pour
s'en persuader tout à fait philippe
gassot et bernard puis ce saut ont passé
la journée sur la plage de la concorde
paris aujourd'hui devenu magique
ceux qui ont échoué sans vacances
s'invente une croisière sur le lagon de
la concorde mais oui en plein paris où
l'on croise parfois des navires de au
bord on a les ports du pacifique qu'on
peut ou vienne en rangs serrés samarrai
les paquebots qui ramène du vent dé
parfum de vanille les adieux sur les
quais sont souvent difficiles d'un
bungalow caché avec vue sur la mer
laissant les rues désertes et les
commerces clos derrière les jardins on
peut prendre tout son temps pour
contempler les flots
le vent et de nos rois de l'arc de
crillon l'anticyclone des açores nous
laisse un peu l'a fait il ya les
pèlerins de paris du pari cartes
postales qui ont beaucoup souffert et
qui pansent leurs plaies
on étudie les fonds sur des cartes
marines pour savoir si enfin les rares
métro croise toujours au large de la
chapelle comme dans les autres creek
l'abominable homme des plages sur de son
physique promène son regard tout comme à
douarnenez on guette le retour des
pêcheurs de crevettes qui reviennent au
hockey il y a comme partout ceux qui ont
une place et ceux qui en cherchent une
avec de l'imagination bien sûr on sait
ce qu'il y a sous les pavés new york et
les états unis connaissent une vague
record de tourisme new york et les états
unis connaissent donc une vague record
de tourisme 16 % de français de plus que
l'an dernier
des touristes agréablement surpris leur
séjour est en facilité par la baisse du
dollar la monnaie américaine continue sa
plongée à londres à zurich à tokyo et à
francfort
le dollar a une nouvelle fois atteint
les cours les plus bas de son histoire
ce qui ne laisse pas d'inquiéter les
dirigeants américains il fallait donner
un marc 92 ce matin à francfort pour
avoir un dollar alors que la veille
c'est un 2 1 marque 95 se négociait la
monnaie américaine cette baisse
régulière qui dure depuis près d'un mois
et la conséquence difficultés
rencontrées par le président carter pour
maîtriser l'inflation américaine
en baisse contre le marque dollar a
également chuté contre le yen et contre
la livre sterling qui a franchi ce matin
la barre des 2 dollars à paris pas de
cotations puisque la bourse elle aussi
faisait le pont mais une séance qui
s'annonce demain agité le dollar
s'échangeait en effet à quatre francs 15
ce matin à londres le conséquence
immédiate de ce désordre monétaire
la bataille économique que se livrent
les grands pays industrialisés sera
rendue plus vive la baisse de l'art et
pour les américains une prime à
l'exportation et puis et surtout le
risque d'une hausse du prix du pétrole
du pays producteurs rechignent en effet
de plus en plus être payé dans une
monnaie fondante
j'ajoute que le directeur de la banque
nationale suisse a réuni cet après midi
les chefs cambistes suisse sans aucun
doute pour traiter de la situation sur
le marché des changes
en iran le gouvernement annonce qu'il
contrôle la situation mais en même temps
il assure que l'armée qui quadrillent
plusieurs villes est prête à intervenir
c'est la preuve qu'ils redoutent
d'autres eme d'autres affrontements
violents comme ceux qui affectent depuis
plusieurs jours une vingtaine de villes
le ch avec vient de faire un geste en
faveur de son opposition en libérant 117
prisonniers cependant le bilan des
dernières émeutes restent difficiles à
établir pour les primes ont gelé et que
le genre d'information environ il semble
cependant que l'agitation se poursuivre
mais d'une façon j'avais quand même on a
vu pour la première fois
les terres leur faire des affaires même
quand la chine s'éveillera
et bien ça y est la chine s'ouvre au
monde on l'a vu avec la signature
récente du traité d'amitié entre pékin
et tokyo
au grand dam de moscou voici maintenant
que le numéro un chinois
wacom fang voyage comme tous les autres
chefs d'état le successeur de mario
arrive aujourd'hui en roumanie
il ira ensuite en yougoslavie les
soviétiques ont l'impression que le
premier chinois marche quelque peu sur
leurs plates-bandes
un seul mot d'ordre dans la politique
chinoise échec aux soviétiques
voilà l'explication du voyage sans
précédent que le numéro un chinois
wako fang entreprend en roumanie et en
yougoslavie même un empereur de chine
n'avait jamais accompli un tel périple
et mao tsé toung n'avait pas osé
dépasser moscou par ce voyage les
dirigeants chinois veulent d'abord salué
ces deux pays du bloc socialiste
la roumanie et la yougoslavie qui ont
mené une certaine politique
d'indépendance à l'égard de moscou
les chinois veulent dénoncer à bucarest
et à belgrade
l'hégémonie soviétique et la politique
de moscou
en afrique la chine veut aujourd'hui
briser l'encerclement géographiques
politiques et militaires de l'urss
en lançant cette offensive diplomatique
vers l'europe
elle vient de faire la même chose avec
le japon en signant samedi à pékin un
traité de paix et d'amitié valable dix
ans une clause de ce traité vise
directement moscou
pékin et tokyo déclare en effet
s'opposer à toute nation qui tentera
d'imposer son hégémonie dans la région
deux pays deux peuples qui se sont fait
la guerre pendant 50 ans oublie ainsi le
passé le désir d'isoler moscou
favorisé par les états unis a été le
plus fort mais aussi la volonté des
industriels japonais de conquérir le
marché chinois
aux termes de cet accord le japon va
exporter vers la chine pour 50 milliards
de francs de produits industriels
les chinois de leur côté vont vendre au
japon charbon et pétrole pour faire
échec à moscou pour développer son
économie la chine de waco fang est prêt
à s'ouvrir plus au monde pékin veut même
normaliser ses relations avec washington
et augmenter ses échanges commerciaux
avec l'europe de l'ouest
madame margaret thatcher leader de
l'opposition conservatrice britannique
qui dès l'année dernière faisait ses
courses au marché de pékin avait
peut-être senti la nouvelle politique
chinoise et puis j'apprends à l'instant
que l'infirmier dissident soviétique
alexandre propre podrabinek a été
condamné à 5 ans d'exil par un tribunal
près de moscou alexandre podrabinek est
considéré comme l'un des éléments les
plus actives de la nouvelle génération
de la dissidence
il était accusé de diffusion d'
inventions de caractère diffamatoire
calomniant le régime soviétique l'étagé
de 25
un geste de bonne volonté du premier
ministre israélien avant le sommet de
camp david entre les états unis l'egypte
et israël
monsieur béguines confirme la suspension
du projet de création de cinq points de
peuplement en cisjordanie
et ce at il précisé pour des raisons
psychologiques au portugal le premier
ministre désigné va-t-il devoir renoncer
à former un gouvernement
monsieur aubrée da costa a de plus en
plus de difficultés depuis que les
socialistes refusent de collaborer le
parti de norio suarez semble résolu
maintenant à passer dans l'opposition
nomination d'un nouveau premier ministre
alfredo nombre et da costa n'aura donc
pas mis fin à la crise gouvernementale
au portugal depuis sa désignation
mercredi dernier par le président arias
neige
monsieur da costa n'a toujours pas
réussi à former un gouvernement
la raison c'est le refus des socialistes
de participer au gouvernement de
coalition que désire le nouveau premier
ministre
mais l'échec pour le moment du moins de
monsieur da costa est surtout un échec
pour le président ramaioli à neige que
l'on voit ici lors de la prestation de
serment du précédent premier ministre
mario soares le président lyonnais
jugeant le gouvernement trop faible pour
vaincre la terrible crise économique et
sociale que traverse le portugal avaient
des mini mario soares et nommé à sa
place monsieur da costa un brillant
technocrate connu pour être un
gestionnaire efficace
lié aux patronne la mission de monsieur
da costa former un gouvernement au
dessus des partis
obtenir la confiance du parlement et
s'attaquer aussitôt à la crise or depuis
mercredi
monsieur da costa est toujours incapable
de former son gouvernement
est ce à cause de mario soares qui
refuse de laisser le parti socialiste
qu'il dirige et qui est le plus nombreux
au parlement
participer au nouveau gouvernement dans
une interview accordée hier mario soares
accuse le président iya neige de n'avoir
pas respecté la constitution et d'avoir
cédé aux pressions de la droite qui veut
récupérer les conquêtes de la révolution
ce matin les socialistes confirmé le
refus d'entrer dans le gouvernement au
cours d'une entrevue avec monsieur da
costa il semble bien que le parti
socialiste ait choisi désormais de se
placer dans l'opposition en france
maintenant le conflit des contrôleurs
aériens
un espoir d'aboutissement le ministre
des transports vient de fixer deux
rendez-vous aux syndicats pour une
reprise de discussions vendredi et
samedi prochains mais il y à une
condition que les aiguilleurs du ciel
n'annonce pas la reprise de leur
mouvement jeudi en assemblée générale
raymond barre par lui même dans
l'hebdomadaire elle le premier ministre
évoque un certain nombre de sujets
personnels
il souligne qu'il ne s'accrochera pas
avec l'énergie du désespoir à sa
fonction de premier ministre et qu'il ne
la quittera pas de manière intempestive
réaction de monsieur jacques blanc après
les critiques de monsieur mitterrand
contre le conseil constitutionnel le
secrétaire général du parti républicain
estime que s'attaquer au conseil
constitutionnel c'est s'attaquer à la
constitution ce qui lui paraît dangereux
avant d'entrer en conclave les cardinaux
doivent devenir plus croyants c'est un
cardinal qui a dit cela ce matin
monseigneur marty en célébrant la messe
en l'église saint louis des français de
rome a ajouté que le saint-esprit ne
dira pas aux cardinaux pour qui voter ni
le nom du nouveau pape
il le redira voyez dieu les catholiques
ont donc fêté aujourd'hui l'assomption
de marie la fête qui célèbre le retour
de la vierge près de dieu dans son âme
et dans son corps
un mystère qui n'a pas toujours été très
bien compris par les chrétiens mais que
monseigneur etchegaray archevêque de
marseille la ville de la bonne mère
trouve pourtant d'actualité d'actualité
de tous les temps ce sens que cette fête
si populaire révèle le ce qui a de plus
profond dans le coeur humain comme
inspiration à survivre et de savoir que
la vierge celle qui a été la créature la
plus aimés de dieu est actuellement
korean auprès de son fils c'est pour
nous tous aussi donc la certitude pour
nous chrétiens en particulier que nous
aussi nous pouvons aspirer à cette
éternité à cette joie le conclave va se
réunir
qu'attendez vous de l'élection du
nouveau pape voyez-vous là aussi ce que
vous appelez la logique de dieu oui
j'espère que dieu sera toujours logique
avec lui-même de confiance dans quel que
soit le nouveau pape
j'ai confiance dans l'avenir de l'église
bien ce que j'attends du pape quand il
sera élu c'est que il continue dans la
voie tracée par un particulier
les jean xxiii et paul vi une voix
largement ouverte vers les hommes est là
aussi où le flou même de l'amour de dieu
pouvant ainsi irriguer des zones qui
sont dans la détresse qui loue qui n'ont
pas assez confiance en eux et je pense
que le nouveau pas pour a comme ses
prédécesseurs donc redonner leur
fraîcheur de l'espérance à l'humanité
voyage au chevet d'un malade il habite
athènes il est vieux il souffre de maux
divers son âge mais surtout il n'a pas
supporté sa confrontation avec notre
monde moderne des médecins tentent de le
guérir car personne n'a envie de le voir
disparaître une consolation il reçoit
visiteurs sur visiteurs je parle bien
sûr de l'acropole au vème siècle avant
notre ère périclès et voulu faire batten
une cité modèle pour l'ensemble des
grecs sur ces directives le grand
sculpteur phidias fait reconstruire
l'acropole détruite par les guerres
médiques avec phidias l'art classique
grecque est à son apogée l'acropole est
un des joyaux du patrimoine culturel
mondial
après vingt-cinq siècles et bien des
vicissitudes ce qui reste aujourd'hui
des édifices de l'acropole une sorte de
squelette tout
rongé blanchi exerce un étrange pouvoir
de fascination et suscite des sentiments
quasi religieux dans le monde entier des
gens modestes sacrifient leurs économies
pour aller une fois rêver sur l'acropole
elle a même ses fidèles qui chaque année
reviennent l'admiré mais même la pierre
fut-elle sublime et périssable le
chef-d'oeuvre de la civilisation grecque
antique est en danger bien voyez je suis
seul à me promener dans le parthénon
c'est absolument interdit au public
simplement parce que en 1977 il y a eu
deux millions et demi de visiteurs dans
le parthénon ce qui représente 5
millions de talons qui ont martelé ce
marbre et bien entendu ça n'était pas
fait pour ça à périclès n'avait pas
prévu une telle foule
alors pour l'instant c'est interdit ce
qui va être fait c'est qu'on va tracer
avec des blancs ce un chemin de bois au
centre du parthénon qui va permettre
dans quelques temps l'entrée des
visiteurs comme cela se faisait jadis
déjà un plancher protège une partie du
sol des propylées qui ouvre l'accès à
l'immense plate forme rocheuse
mais il ya des menaces plus grave les
poutres de faire placer dans tous les
monuments lors d'une restauration
générale en 1913 ont fini après 60 ans
parce oxydé il en résulte un gonflement
du métal qui fait éclater les blocs de
marbre
on ne peut incriminer personne ni même
parlé d'erreurs au début du siècle la
science ne disposait d'aucun autre moyen
pour cette consolidation qui tourne
aujourd'hui au désastre alors sous les
arches hits rap des propylées
comme sous les plafonds de layton on
place des étais avant de remplacer le
faire-part du titane inoxydable cette
extraordinaire travail durera six ans la
pollution atmosphérique enfin le soufre
contenu dans l'air se dépose sur la
pierre au contact de l'humidité il
devient un acide qui attaquent le marbre
et le rambo dès lors tous ceux qui
exercent une action mécanique quelconque
suffit à ronger les monuments la pluie
et même le vent deviennent redoutable il
a fallu abriter les cariatides sous un
auvent
les qualités perdre leur surface
original et on doit prendre des mesures
pour les sauver de cette destruction
donc on va les enlever on va les enlever
et les remplacer par des copies les
copies seront en ciment et vont rester
jusqu'à ce que la science moderne
trouvent des moyens pour consolider le
marbre les pierres qui ont le sont
attaqués par la part le progrès moderne
je veux dire la pollution atmosphérique
alors regardez les bien elles seront
bientôt comme les bibelots précieux sous
une vitrine
elle y rejoindront ce qui restait des
frontons du parthénon sculpté par
phidias ce que nous voyons ici est déjà
une copie
vous pensez qu'il faut combien d'années
pour sauver réellement l'acropole fou un
dizaine d'années en vain mais c'était
une question que je n'avais que jamais
on est obligé de temps en temps de faire
la même opération pas tout à fait le
même
est ce que maintenant on sait et le
maire assé la maladie on sait les moyens
de soigner un choix nier et je pense et
que avec des méthodes plus modernes que
chaque année nous avons des méthodes des
remèdes du modèle on va utiliser ses
limites mais je ne crois pas que ce sera
nécessaire d'enlever chaque fois les
carriers dit pour le monde il y en a
puisque le même problème ne se pose pas
pour tous les autres sites de la grèce
antique
oui mais pas dans la mesure qu'elle
s'est rendue ficultés à l'acropole parce
que l'acropole est à ranger dans une
vaste ville de millions elles sont les
voitures sont le bus et tous les bus
passent par l'aco paul
la grèce va dépenser un milliard et demi
de drachmes à 150 millions de francs
lourd pour sauver ses monuments antiques
elle a demandé l'aide technique des
experts internationaux la règle imposée
et qu'aucune restauration ne soient
irréversibles
il sera alors toujours possible dans
l'avenir d'utiliser les progrès de la
science
ainsi sera conserver aussi longtemps qu
il se pourra l'héritage laissé au monde
par la démocratie athénienne le berceau
de notre civilisation
le tiercé secours est à deauville
lacombe visiter à la combinaison
gagnante et le neuf le 6 et le 15
autrement dit barbotan ball nordine &
more and more et les rapports les voici
3802 front 52 6 francs dans l'ordre et
dans un ordre différent 760 35 ans pour
5 francs
un tir c'est quand même moins
intéressante que celui de dimanche garde
et en football coupe d'europe des clubs
c'est le lever de rideau
monaco le champion de france se mesure
ce soir à l'étoile de bucarest rencontre
difficile pour les monégasques
bien que l'entraîneur lucien leduc ne
voit pas forcément la partie perdue à je
pense qu'ils n'ont mais je pense que
nous allons voir lucien leduc dans
quelques instants
sinon henry bodiguel vous pouvez nous
dire d'ores et déjà ce que représente
cette rencontre mais il est certain
qu'au point de vue palmarès l'avantagé
dans le camp des rouges
les routes ont une longue expérience de
ces différentes compétitions et en plus
la plupart de leurs joueurs sont
internationaux
d'autre part le championnat roumain
n'est pas encore commencée ce qu'il leur
a permis de se concentrer sur la
préparation de cette coupe d'europe de
ce tour préliminaire de la coupe
d'europe et ils ont pu notamment
participé au tournoi d'athènes au cours
duquel ils ont battu les athéniens par 2
but à 0 l'austria de vienne par 4 buts à
0 ce qui est plus remarquable est en
finale ils ont battu les japonais par 8
buts à 1
du côté de monaco il est certain que le
début en championnat de monaco n'a pas
été spécialement brillant il avait même
été un peu laborieux si ce n'est la
victoire contre son show au dernier jour
du championnat
par ailleurs les monégasques n'ont pas
une grosse expérience des coupes
d'europe
ou quand des calinon ils ont rarement
dépassé les premier ou le deuxième tour
et ensuite les joueurs sont tous très
jeunes
ce qui fait qu'ils vont manquer
certainement
soir de l'expérience internationale qui
est nécessaire dans ce type de
compétition
j'ajoute à cela que la chaîne y la
chaleur qui règne actuellement sur la
côte les a obligés à s'entraîner ou bien
très tôt le matin ou bien très tard le
soir ce qui n'est pas la solution idéale
d'autant que cette rencontre arrive très
tôt dans le calendrier puisque nous ne
sommes pas tous que le 15 août
alors pourquoi elle arrive si tôt et
bien en fait ce soir on dispute une
sorte de match de barrage situation qui
était provoquée par le retour de
l'albanie dans la coupe d'europe des
clubs champions et ce retour de
l'albanie portait le nombre des équipes
à 33 il n'en fallait que 32 il fallait
donc organisé un tour préliminaire pour
éliminer l'équipe supplémentaires un
tirage au sort a eu lieu et il a désigné
monaco et bucarest pour 10 e pour
disputer cette espèce de match de
barrage on pourrait d'ailleurs s'étonner
à ce propos que l'albanie puisqu'elle
est à l'origine de la situation n'est
pas été désignés d'office pour
participer à ce tour préliminaire de la
coupe d'europe des clubs champions
bon alors je vous proposais tout al
heure d'écouté lucien leduc l'entraîneur
le voici je pense dans quelques instants
lucien leduc il y a quelques jours
justement à l'entraînement de sonic que
j'ai vu jouer cet adversaire il est fort
mais je connais pas de l'équipe qu'il
soit imbattable
moi je vais bus ou un très bon jour il
est une équipe qui comme les autres que
alors misons des mauvais jours comme
nous on peut avoir dix ans si on a des
mauvais jours dans des bons aussi j'ai
su que dans un bon jour on peut donner
la réplique
alors le chien leduc vous avez
pratiquement tout connu avec vos deux
équipes de monaco c'est le 10 à 15 ans
et celle de maintenant sauf la coupe
d'europe
oui sauf la coupe d'europe non c'est une
compétition évidemment particulière je
crois qu'il faut la jouer évidemment
disons sont complexes
même si par exemple je n'en avais pas
été voir cet adversaire là que je
connaissais quand même par ouï dire eh
bien on va peut-être été influencée de
le penser que malgré tout disons
bucarest mais croient qu'ils font quand
même des coupes d'europe depuis une
dizaine d'années voilà pour le football
nous reprenons la mère maintenant en
effet les vingt bateaux du tour de
france à voile après avoir traversé le
canal du midi entament la deuxième
partie de l'épreuve en méditerranée
cette fois au cours de l'étape de la
grande-motte marseille
nous retrouvons l'équipe d'antenne 2 qui
est aussi un équipage puisque notre
maison participent à la course avec en
régaler
contrairement à certaines étapes de la
manche et de l'atlantique le vent ne
fait pas défaut ici en méditerranée aux
vingt bateaux du tour de france à la
voile l'équipage de marseille est
toujours en tête de classement une
première place qu'il ne semble pas près
de céder car comme on le dit dans le
langage cycliste ce sont les régionaux
de l'état et le bateau s'est montré le
plus régulier de l'épreuve dans le
peloton des voiliers du tour de france
sept aux couchers de soleil et sur les
ondes que le contact se maintient on
pourra ainsi des nouvelles d'un bateau à
l'autre mais la vhf c'est surtout un bon
moyen de lutter contre le sommeil
d'échanger des informations pour les
équipages les moins aguerris pour le
voilier du journal d'antenne 2 présent
sur la course est en outre un outil bien
pratique pour bavarder avec les
équipages des bateaux
qu'est ce qui va faire les équipages qui
vont gagner là d'après vous sur cette
deuxième partie après marseille le tour
de france ferait escale à toulon saint
raphaël puis il arrivait à menton le 20
août sur presque tous les voiliers une
d'équipage par bateau se seront succédés
c'est un des buts atteints par
l'organisateur de l'épreuve donner à des
jeunes français et des moins jeunes
l'occasion de faire de la voile sans
bourse délier ce sont en effet vingt
villes et régions qui en apportant une
contribution financière qu'ont permis de
réaliser ce premier tour de france à la
voile avant de passer à la météo une
dernière minute qui nous vient de
tunisie et qui concerne le procès des
syndicalistes à sousse bernard pradines
aux biens le tribunal s'est désisté in
sang un syndicaliste étaient impliqués
dans les incidents survenus à sousse au
cours de la grève générale du 26 janvier
dernier le tribunal criminel de sousse
et donc désisté il considère que la
sphère est de la compétence de la cour
de sûreté de l'état en tunisie donc pas
de verdict car on attendait le verdict
ce soir la météo maintenant orages étant
variable voilà ce que prévoit cette
météo pour demain
les orages éclateront dans toutes les
régions montagneuses et seront parfois
violents
temps variable sur les régions de
l'ouest avec de belles éclaircies des
landes au morbihan à 23h05 bernard
pradines au sera à votre rendez vous
pour le dernier journal mais celui ci
n'est pas terminée car je voudrais que
nous évoquions quelques souvenirs
il y a un an moore est un roi elvis
presley en ce 15 août à memphis aux
états unis voulaient enterrer des
milliers de fans sont venus pleurer sur
sa tombe
toute une époque toute une jeunesse
elvis presley 1968 après une éclipse
il retrouvait gloire et honneur pas
forcément le bonheur et c'est avec cette
elvis de cette époque là est aussi
l'elvis des dernières chansons que nous
allons terminer ce journal
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée
il
faux
j'ai moi
bravo
itou
oui